[Music]
ladies and gentlemen let me announce
here mr. goldbloom is having a very
important birthday in just four days yes
that's true next Monday and you will be
is it okay yeah it's 60 you'll be sixty
years old that's all the birthday
celebrate if nothing else happened
besides that that I will feel it's been
celebrated what lovely scent moment
you're gonna have a party yeah you know
and once again Emily is gonna give me a
party I never have a party but she's
going to I know it's not a surprise
she's been saying you know hey how about
you know I know your friend is this do
you want them over you know and they'll
come over the house and we'll have a
little bit of not had one call you like
the cup if you would like to come boy
you'd be a wonderful person to have on
my birthday I'm a lot of fun at a party
of course you're a fun of the bar I do
insist we watch tapes of my show I bring
a lot of DVDs but you see this episode I
really give it so insane in and what
after watching Church like silence yeah
yeah
not even laughing never probably do you
so are you gonna have you're gonna have
a party are you good at the whole like
happy birthday you know oh no I'm
embarrassed that's why I'd never have
parties no I don't want to be even on
the movie set or stuff you're working
I'm sure you do it when your birthday
comes around don't they have a cake it
of it I hate oh I don't like it either
and they try to surprise you oh you know
Conan where there's a meeting come down
for a notes we have a meeting we have to
meet down on the stage and you go oh I
think I know what this is happy birthday
do you know it's all you can do to
endure that happy birthday it's okay
everybody's sweet but no I don't want to
hold it but all in all it'll be okay
it'll be fine
and I certainly don't want to open
presents I'm not a good I don't want
anything and I don't they won't make me
you know even if they bring presents and
I hope they don't you know they're not
gonna make me oh look what look what
Gary got me oh it was incredible what
you just did was about sixty five
sentences strung together
fantastic encourage you at home
[Applause]